thanks and good yeah so this is going to
be a tutorial in two parts so I'm going
to talk about one flavor of codes for
cloud storage
Alex DeMarcus is going to start talk is
going to talk on Thursday and Friday
about a second flavor of codes and then
the first part is also in two parts and
welcome to part one
so unlike jaikumar i cannot assume that
the objects i'm going to talk about are
intrinsically worthy of study you know
two-party communication has been studied
for over 30 years now the codes that we
are going to talk about or at most five
years old so I'm going to spend some
time trying to convince you that these
are actually objects with study so let's
start from what is the problem that we
are trying to solve well the problem is
us basically there's a huge amount of
data that we are all generating and we
then expect that this data is going to
be stored somewhere out there in such a
way that we can access it whenever we
want from laptops from our phones and so
on and so forth
and on top of that we'd like to have all
this storage for free all right so how
does this really happen and Before we
jump into this I mean we've all heard
these numbers but I thought it might be
good to do a little toy experiment about
you know how much data is really being
stored out there so to start with you
know when I go home I'm going to have to
prove that I actually did something
today so let's say I decide to take a
photo just to prove that you know I
actually give a talk here I can't get my
phone to switch on so let's just pretend
I took a photo
how much does you know maybe I said oh
okay so anyway how much does a typical
photo if I take in one on a phone like
this what size is it well I actually
checked this out just for the stock I
didn't know the answer either a
reasonable answer is that it's in the
range of say around 300 kilobytes 200 to
400 kilobytes right so how much is that
300 kilobytes is basically 3 into 10 to
the 5 by
let's measure everything in bytes right
and let's say that on average I take one
photo a day and there's about 60 days in
the year so in one year just the photos
I take alone it's going to be something
like this number into 365 now if you're
only interested in orders of magnitude
and I checked this before I came here I
think this is about 10 to the 8th all
right so this is about 100 MB of data
that I'm generating on my phone every
year how many smartphones are out there
in the world again I don't really expect
anyone to know the answer to this it's
about a billion right so it's about 10
to the 9 smartphones let's multiply
these two and you know this is pretty
average usage I'm not even talking about
videos and things like that there's
people who have cats and so on who
obviously will take way more phones
photos than I so in total just from
photos from smartphones alone the total
volume you see out there is something
like 10 to the 17 bytes so okay we all
know what a gigabyte is that's 10 to the
9
then comes a terabyte which is 10 to the
12
then comes a petabyte which is 10 to the
15 this is about hundred petabytes of
data and you know it's a huge number and
by no means eventually all of this finds
its way onto the cloud somewhere right
like when I actually managed to switch
my phone on and connect it to my
computer there's like three competing
programs that want to back it up or to
their own cloud right so all of this
data eventually finds its way out to the
cloud how much does it cost to actually
store this amount of information now we
also heard two isms like data is cheap
like storage is cheap right so the total
data stored in the cloud it's of the
order of exabytes exabytes is like 10 to
the 18 it's you know maybe a few tens or
hundreds of exabytes at this time a
terabyte hard drive on
will cost you about a hundred dollars
right so it is cheap but not compared to
the scale of data that you actually need
to store so just during the raw data
okay on this kind of commodity hard
drives is going to cost you hundreds of
millions of dollars so hardware is cheap
in the sense that you know a you know X
amount of storage costs you much less
now than it did before but just the
amount of data where the store is
completely insane and okay so this is
and get somehow began all this unlimited
cloud storage for free right so what's
going on here this is the fundamental
problem that this work is trying to
address right and is this just about you
know saving big bucks for companies like
Microsoft and Google which is not
terribly exciting to me and should not
be exciting to people here in this
audience but you know there's more to it
than that
data centers they consume about 3% of
all global electricity production this
you know I got it from the internet take
it the grain of salt but you know data
center footprint is a real concern for
you know of currently and these numbers
they look pretty big by themselves but
that's until you start multiplying them
by a factor of three so why would you do
that well this is the way that data
storage has been done till very recently
so okay let's start from the most basic
scenario where I have something like six
machines well when I talk about machines
I'm just thinking about hard drive
storing data let's say that goal is just
to tolerate one disk failure the
simplest thing that you could do here is
to just duplicate all your data it gives
you a 2x overhead the advantage of
course is that recovery is very quick
suppose you know you request your email
and that machine is down for some reason
we just direct you to a second machine
and you don't notice any difference
so the overhead you're paying is pretty
large in terms of reliability if you
just want it to tolerate one disk
failure from these six machines there's
a much simpler solution at least a more
space efficient solution which is just
treat just use a simple eggs or
basically the parity check code this is
what r85 does you treat each of your
disks as this huge big fix as this huge
MIT vector and you just you have five
data this the six disk will store the
eggs all of these right so this gives
you a 1.2 X overhead which is much
better in terms of storage space the
price you pay is slower recovery like
suppose now I request my email and that
machine happens to be down what's really
going on is that you're reading data
from five other machines exerting all
that data together so you know it's
obviously something that's going to be
much slower now let's talk about two
disk failures so then okay so this is
kind of what was the-- or what is the
industry standard because most places
which store data are still doing
duplication right so you just take
everything do replicate it tries it has
the same advantage of quicker recovery
but now the price of course is that your
overhead is three times in place of this
rate six would use a six for Reed
Solomon code where basically what you do
is you have four data discs and then you
generate two more parity disk now the
what is the cost here the cost is slower
recovery as before if you actually have
two failures now it's not even as simple
as you just exert a bunch of things
together it's actually a small two by
two system of linear equations that you
need to solve okay so all right so now
reed-solomon codes are the first
solution anyone would think of when
they're trying to switch away from
replication so everybody in this
audience has probably seen reed-solomon
codes before but just you know for
someone like when Kurt who hasn't seen
reed-solomon codes I'm going to
introduce them
so you have something like K data
symbols at n minus K parity check
symbols which are generated from these
data symbols using some you know linear
combinations over finite fields and the
really awesome thing about reed-solomon
codes is that the field size is just
linear in n if by the end of this
tutorial I can convince you that this is
you know it's really a miracle of nature
then this tutorial will have been
successful and the nice thing about
reed-solomon codes is that they are
maximum distance separable what this
means is that okay you have Kiedis worth
of data there obviously you need kid is
surviving in order to recover your data
and MDS the being at the MDS bond
guarantees that it doesn't matter which
K to survive
you can have some mixture of data and
parity discs as long as you have K does
your data is safe so now the question is
what parameters of N and K should we be
using in practice we are using 4 6 6 B
we talked about 6 for reed-solomon codes
which is what rate does you know why the
setting of parameters could you do
something differently and here is the
sum what you know to anyone coming from
a communications perspective from the
communications worldview whenever you
transmit over a channel you assume there
is a fixed failure probability P so
naturally as your codes grow longer and
longer you expect the redundancy to
scale linearly well in storage it just
seems that people do not scale
redundancy linearly like this this is
how it is now this is actually going to
be important to what goes what I am
going to talk about so I'll try and you
know give you some rationalization of
why this is the case this is basically
the case because disk failure rates are
really low so think about the
probability that a disk is going to
crash on any given day we know from
experience that this is not very high
right
yes this probability of failure P is
something really really tiny so let's
say that we initially are coding over
tenders now we go to twenty days now
expectation is linear so I expect you
know the expected number of discs that
will crash is going to be twice but two
times epsilon is still a very small
number it's very close to zero right and
what are people trying to do when they
switch from replication to cooling the
goal is only to make sure that your data
is as safe now as it was before when
they were doing replication is this the
right thing to do
I don't know so when you started off
using your email provider in 2005 you
know they were doing replication let's
say now they are using some other error
correcting code they have so much more
data so many more users now your data is
probably as safe as it was before maybe
even a little safer now just with the
increase in the number of users you
assume that they are having more
failures and that's probably true but
you know they try to they don't try to
ensure that okay the chance that I never
see a failure now is going to be the
same as it was in 2005 they just want to
say that each person's data is as safe
as it was before so they're comparing
themselves to three very application and
now you start to see why it is that you
don't necessarily need to scale
redundancy linearly say that P is the
probability of disk failure with three V
replication your failure probability
would be something like PQ and if you
have K users you know it would be well
it's at least PQ it's more like K times
P cubed now let's say I'm using a
reed-solomon code which has distance
even one better so you need four
failures for data loss right so now
these each event which causes data loss
has probability something like P to the
food not sure you're coding over K
machines so there are something like K
choose for possible bad events
but still these numbers are so small
that this number is still you know going
to be very smaller than this so you know
it's not the in some sense this is how
it is when people with the current
numbers when the lengths of good
increase the redundancy does not scale
linearly something little o of K like
you know maybe even logarithmic seems to
be sufficient
now given that if you accept this as a
given then really instead of using a 6-4
reed-solomon code you could use
something like say you know a 60 50
reed-solomon code or a hundred hundred
five reed-solomon or you know basically
the overhead should be going close to
zero you know just by using longer and
longer codes because the redundancy is
not scaling linearly so is this what
really happens the answer is not really
you cannot do this because the cost of
recovering data then would just be too
high and this is the MDS property coming
back to bite us
typically the failures you see are not
three and four disk failures they're
just single disk failures right and by
the MDS property of reed-solomon codes
even to recover this one discs worth of
data you have to read key other discs in
entirety this is a property that we use
all the time and designing secret
sharing scheme for instance saying you
know now it's not such a desirable
property and the trouble really is that
now you are in a distributed storage
system these discs you know maybe
they're distributed across data centers
across locations and so on each disk
read is pretty costly right so having to
wait till 25 distress point to you
you'll probably never be able to serve
users data so this is what limits us in
practice to using small values of K in
reed-solomon codes and of course if the
length that you can use is you know only
of the order of 20 and 25 then you need
some amount of redundancy there like you
know three or four so you won't actually
get overheads which go towards once so
let me say a bit more about the kind of
these failure scenarios which are
typical the most important failure
scenario is what is called a degraded
read so the idea here is just that
somebody is requesting their data and
that particular machine is either failed
or it's slow or it's down for an upgrade
or something like that
right so if you were doing replication
of course then you could just you know
direct that request somewhere else if
you're using a racial coding something
like reed-solomon then there's more work
involved
you need to read clear disks compute out
some linear combination and serve back
to the user in fact if you were using
something like read Solomon
since any K does suffice what you'd
probably try and do is to read all these
disks that are available and you know
the first K which respond to you you use
that to serve the request so these kinds
of reads are called degraded reads disk
failure is a much more unlikely event so
what happens here is that okay a discus
filled and we've decided that we want to
replace it now again the same thing
happens but the main difference is that
now you just try to recreate it on some
other machine and there's not some
person who's actually waiting there for
this data to be served okay so now the
question is can we do better using
arrays you're coding right so and it's
clear that there's something here the
just rate distance trade-offs are not
going to capture for you because if
Solomon codes are optimal as far as you
know meeting the singleton bound cause
it's some other property you need which
addresses you know how much time is
going to take you to fix these typical
failures right and there have been two
notions so the first question is to
identify what it is that we want to
optimize now and there have been two
notions proposed in the literature to
address this the first of these it's
work that you know started right here in
Berkley work on regenerating quartz due
to demarcus Godfrey who Wainwright and
round children and now this is a
thriving body of work
the metric that they identify here is
network bandwidth they say that in order
to recover a single
discontents I don't want to communicate
too much data over the network locally
repairable codes were you know they were
they were introduced a couple of years
later and I'll you know tell you a
longer story about how they came to be
but the metric here is the number of
disks that you need to read the number
of disks that need to respond to you in
order for you to serve the users request
right so you want to imagine a scenario
where you know which is common in data
centers that the disks are doing a lot
of things they are serving other readers
requests and so on and so forth so every
time you ask to read something from the
disk it's not that you get what you want
immediately you have to stand in queue
that disk finishes whatever it's doing
and then eventually catch to you so it's
important that you know you don't try
and you don't need a response from too
many disks so the metric here is the
number of disk reads and for reasons
that I don't fully understand and
perhaps alex will explain later
they gonna do this in reverse
chronological order so I'll talk about
LRC's first and then he's going to talk
about regenerating so one question might
be which of these is the right model
right so this is a bit like asking if
you have an algorithm do you want it to
be time efficient or space efficient you
know you want both right so this is and
in fact there is a lot of work at this
point which tries to get the best of
both worlds in this talk though I'm
going to focus on local irreparable
goals so part 1 of this tutorial is
going to focus on this notion of
locality I'm going to introduce a formal
definition which captures this notion
and we'll talk about great distance
trade-offs when locality is also
something that we care about and in
tomorrow's talk will address the
reliability aspect of these codes or in
more depth there so we'll tie in us what
kind of failures are the actually trying
to tolerate its minimum distance really
what we want from our codes or is it
some
thing else Oh so locality so locality is
a notion who is you know I would say
it's time not only as its time come it's
come several times over in that past few
years there have been several works in
the literature all of which
independently identified that this is
the problem with reed-solomon codes and
some notion like this would fix it so
there is this work of Jen Wong and Lee
from 2007 and then you know a lot of
many other independent works following
that a formal definition of locality was
given in this paper which is joint work
with Sergei who is here and cheng huang
and hussein symmetry so they say that
okay so I'm going to talk only about
linear codes in body stars in it so
they're going to say a coordinate in a
linear code has locality are if I can
recover this coordinate from our other
symbols in the code since it's a linear
code this means that I can write this
coordinate as some linear combination of
these are other symbols in the code so
there's a very simple definition this is
what locality is yes sorry so you know
so a simplest example is that in a in a
to 3 parity check code where I have X 1
X 2 X 1 plus X 2 every coordinate has
locality 2 because I can read I can take
about X 1 by reading X 2 and X 1 plus X
2 you know well that's the length of the
code so there's nothing non-trivial
going on here
but in any code the locality is of a
particular coordinate is okay this
coordinate is something how do I suppose
this coordinate is lost what is the
smallest number of other coordinates I
can then read to write this thing to
express this as a linear combination of
the score
yes I mean otherwise the you know so if
it's a cold right presumably it has some
distance so by reading everything else
you can certainly recover this
coordinate or reading you know is it any
other our coordinates you could read and
you get it back or is it a specific it
has to be a specific set of oh sorry
sorry sorry it said you know it it
cannot be any other coordinates you know
for if if the earth coordinate is lost
then you say oh look there is the set
there doomed to this particular
coordinate that I can read which will
recover it for me so basically this says
that if CI is lost it can be recovered
by reading just our other symbols which
are other symbols of course depends on
which I which coordinate I was the very
distinguish between two kinds of
locality one is data locality
now data locality is a notion which
applies only to systematic linear codes
and actually I should have said that in
this talk we are only going to talk
about systematic linear codes because
the systematic property is very
important in data storage you do want a
rock or P of everybody's data there in
addition to that you can have some
encoded information as well so data
locality is where all the data symbols
are guaranteed to have locality are so
this really captures this degraded trade
scenario that if somebody is requesting
their data then that I can serve by
reading just our other coordinates which
is our other disks right now no one is
ever going to ask for the XOR of my
email your email and this person's email
so you know if we the notion of locality
for the parity check symbols is not as
natural it won't come up in the degraded
rate scenario but of course this could
crash and then to maintain reliability
you have to reconsider these symbols as
well so it is a natural notion - right
and if every people consider two kinds
of course codes with data locality are
and codes with all symbol locality or
so what is the bottom line here I mean
you're doing something very simple we're
just saying that okay we are trying to
decouple the complexity of typical kind
of failures from the complexity of worst
case failures because a lot of time in
data centers you really are dealing with
single disk failures in fact it's often
not even failures it's things like you
know Windows needs to upgrade every once
in three days so you're taking a bunch
of machines down you'll do it carefully
of course but while the machines are
down
you do need to serve these Ricou so the
important thing is that once your
overhead drops below 2x you only have
one copy of the real data sitting in the
wrong so if that data is for some reason
of it unavailable you have to use the
code in order to serve these requests so
you're giving you this definition it
guarantees our rates for single failures
it doesn't give any guarantees for worst
case failures right and really what you
want is our rates not just for single
failures but our rates for whatever the
typical failure scenario might be and
we'll talk about this later
in tomorrow's talk ok so this is a good
starting this is a good point to talk
about where these codes at least they're
you know where'd these girls came from
so locally decodable and testable codes
they are very well studied in the
computer science literature so the first
work on LD sees was probably the gold
right leaven result which gave a list a
local list decoder for Hadamard codes
this notion was formally defined in work
of kags and Travis on in 2000 and by now
there's a body of beautiful work on it
and Sergey here has written a book on
this topic and really I would say that
this notion of local decoding was
implicit at least in early works in
coding theory like reads majority logic
decoder for raid molar codes which I'm
sure a lot of you are familiar with he
didn't stated in the language of locally
decodable codes but it's way a lot of
these majority logic kind of decoders
it's very easy to think
of them as local decoders for course and
the goal here is to have local decoding
up to the minimum distance so this is
typically in the scenario of errors
rather than erasers but we can think
about it even for editors think of the
number of erasers as minimum distance
minus 1 I'm still guaranteeing that each
coordinate arrays coordinate I can
recover by reading just our other
coordinates much stronger than what we
are aiming for in the stock right okay
now yeah low-density parity-check codes
because they're in one low density in in
the parity check matrix so I don't think
so
you know so I I'm sure people have their
we by now know how to construct expander
codes for instance which have good
locality properties so this might be a
specific instance where you get both
these properties but I don't normally
any very general connection check-check
with small degree is a local with her
group that is small so you will get
locality just by having one check for
one check covering every symbol so yeah
so this course with its small dense yeah
such course would probably get into your
locality in our sense but I don't know
LDC is a very strong notion and you know
I don't know if a genetic relation of
the kind that you're asked which is
harder thing than just covering
everything with a small local group so
there is connection so locally decodable
codes now again it's a very strong
definition and the problem is that these
are really hard to construct you know if
you want constant locality for constant
relative distance so you're guaranteeing
locality not for one failure but like
you know n over 100 phase
years then you actually have super
linear lower bounds on the encoding
length so this is in the early work of
cats and Trevisan in fact it's very
interesting that if you read the
introduction to their paper they say
that such codes would have given
fault-tolerant storage with unlimited
scalability they realize that this would
be a really terrible thing so they prove
a lower bound saying that such codes are
actually not possible unfortunately then
in slam the door shut you know hard
enough so you know so the best
constructions we have are
superpolynomial and off lake there's
been a line of work where we relax the
locality constraint we say that we don't
want constant locality we are willing to
you know end to the epsilon is also
great for instance and now we are
actually seeing codes which have rate
and they have fairly high rate so okay
so this is certainly something which you
know influenced us in our work I should
also mention the notion of locally
testable codes which solves the
membership in the code problem with
locality which are closely related to
locality codes so let's start by
examining this notion of codes which
have data locality so data locality
means every information symbol can be
expressed as a linear combination of our
other coordinates so this is a very
simple motion it's also very simple to
achieve this was already you know
observed in this paper on pyramid codes
where they say well if you want a code
with data locality there's a very simple
way to get it from Reed Solomon codes
just take the first parity I kind of
break it up let's assume that the first
parity in the reed-solomon code is just
a simple XOR
now instead of being the simple exhort
of everything you just do the obvious
thing but you break your data symbols
into groups of size R write down the
parity for that now you spent ki over R
additional parity checks and you've got
your distance up to right now you throw
in the remaining parity checks from the
reed-solomon codes this gives you a
final code which has distance D and
whose length is something like K times 1
plus 1 over R right because
you have the K data symbols you spend
keyword are just to get this locality
property so this is a simple
construction but it incurs this linear
overhead in terms of key to get the
locality property right and remember
that we said that B is pretty small
compared to key so here it's not the
distance but it's the locality that's
causing the linear overhead the question
of course is whether this is really
necessary now okay now if you wanted
locality for all symbols again there's a
very simple thing you can do you have a
bunch of parity checks lying around well
you know throw a local parity for them
as well if you do this in the most
obvious way then you know you you know
basically the length scales up by a
factor of R plus 1 over R and now you
get locality for everything again you
could ask is this the best one can do so
this is basically in other words what
we're really asking is what are the
trade-offs between NK and D the usual
parameters of a linear chord and this
new parameter we've introduced which is
the locality R so in this work what we
show is this that in any linear code
even if you only care for information
locality then the overhead you need is K
over R plus D minus 2 it's exactly what
you're getting from this pyramid code
construction so the high order message
is that if you want locality you need a
linear overhead conversely if you could
say that if somebody wants a storage
system and their overhead is only one
point one X that means there are going
to be some degraded roots which will
require you to read something like ten
other machines all right so yeah just
rewriting this so that the linear
overhead is necessary moreover you know
we can show that essentially such codes
need to look extremely simple they
basically need to look like this pyramid
code construction in the following sense
to make our life simple I'm going to
make the assumption that this parameter
R divided ski ideally you have this huge
file which been cutting assuming
chunks that really you know key you can
make some simple divisibility
assumptions about it it's not
unreasonable at all so what we can show
is that if our device key then any code
which achieves this bound with equality
it looks like this essentially you take
your okay so there's also a restriction
here that the distance D needs to be
sufficiently small which I'm brushing
under the carpet but with these
restrictions any code just like needs to
look like this you basically take your
data symbols break them into groups of
size R you write down a parity check for
each of them and then you have these
remaining parity checks if B is small
this actually will not have locality are
they cannot so you'll see why this is
the case when I show you the proof of
this lower bound in a minute so I guess
one comment about this is that if the
locality so locality K is usually it's
always easy to achieve reed-solomon
codes do that because any symbol you
can't recover by reading K other symbols
right if you plug in R equals K here
what you get back is the singleton bound
as an extension to the case where you
want non-trivial locality so what
happens in the setting so K codes with
data locality we're saying that we
understand them pretty well not only do
we know the best length you can achieve
we also understand a fair bit about the
structure of any such code which is
fairly rigid in the setting of small D
the only freedom you have in some sense
is how you choose these parity checks
these D minus 2 non-trivial parity
checks so now in the setting of course
with all symbol locality we say that the
only way such a code can achieve all
symbol locality is the following you can
partition these coordinates into groups
of size R plus 1 which satisfy a simple
locality relation
right more actually it's a much stronger
statement which we'll get to when I
actually do the proof so one thing that
this says however the lower bound stays
the same yeah that's the point I want to
make you do not get a stronger lower
bound right so in some sense if you want
to achieve locality here you can't just
do the obvious thing of take these
parity checks and put a local parity on
them each parity check that you add it
needs to increase the distance and then
for some reason these things happen to
satisfy a local relation so do such
chords actually exist
and the answer is that they do so in
this paper be sure that they exist over
sufficiently large fields by some non
explicit probabilistic construction our
sequence of subsequent works actually
makes this explicit and gives you codes
with all symbol locality which meet this
lower bound so ok so let me just tell
you about these results and then in the
remaining time yes q is the field size
yes yes q sorry I didn't mention what Q
is so yeah we say that you can get all
symbol locality but in our proof
you know it's non explicit and we only
prove it for very large field sizes so
explicit constructions by now there are
three at least three of them more in
fact there was one due to Tom Oh Popeye
Leo pullers and DeMarcus which works
which all of these constructions will
give you all symbol locality the first
construction uses a combination of
reed-solomon with some ideas from
Metroid theory another construction due
to silverstein a tile again the length
the field size is exponential in the
length of the code their construction is
based on gaba deulim codes which are
basically linearized analogues of
reed-solomon codes finally a very nice
and elegant but all of these are elegant
but you know a recent construction due
to bargain tunnel it gets the field size
down to linear and these are based on
trade Solomon codes okay so the plan for
the talk now is that I'm going to show
you this lower bound and then time
permitting I'd like to show you as many
of these constructions as I can
so if you can switch the projector off
now that'll be great just tell em to
switch off the project
thank you yeah
so the first order of the day is to
prove this lower bound saying that if a
code has you have an nkd linear code in
your code C which has data locality R
then the length must be at least key
plus ceiling of K over R plus D minus 2
all right
so want me to prove this there are a lot
of proofs by this time is to use the
following view of codes I'm going to
think of a linear code C as being
specified by a sequence of points C 1
through CN living in FQ to the key where
n is the length of the code and K is the
dimension so think of these as just a
set of end points in k dimensional space
and to encode any message X using C you
write out the inner product of X with
all these end points think of these as
measurements so this is what a code is
for us now obviously the first thing you
want is that the C 1 through CN they
ought to be fully dimensional otherwise
this is not enough information to
recover X so having good distance means
that the code is very robustly fully
dimensional in that so ok now let's
imagine an adversary who comes up who
comes along and erases some of these
inner products that we have so if we get
some subset of these inner products then
and now we are trying to reconstruct X
from that as long as the subset which
remains is fully dimensional we know
that we'll be able to get X back right
so having distance D
is just saying that any subset of so let
me put it this way any subset obtained
from C by removing B minus 1 points is
k-dimensional which is to say it's full
dimensional so by turning the statement
around you can think of it as a way of
proving an upper bound on the distance
of a code exhibit a large collection of
points which is only K minus one
dimensional if you managed to find that
then you're proving that the distance of
the school is not too great and so the
plan of attack is basically that they're
going to exhibit a K minus 1 dimensional
subspace in an MDS code you'd only get
size K minus 1 here we'll get something
which is larger by a factor of 1 plus 1
over R why are we going to be able to do
that well what is locality in this view
for a coordinate to have locality R it
basically means it satisfies a linear
relation with some our other points
right so now let's think of these R plus
1 points there are R plus 1 of them but
they're all sitting in an R dimensional
subspace or smaller right so this code
has living inside it
many of these are dimensional subspaces
which actually contain one more point
than you'd expect in an MDS code the
plan is simply to stitch these subspaces
together to the point where we get a K
minus 1 dimensional subspace so they're
going to think of this ok so now let me
set up some notation I'm going to define
this hyper graph H v/e where the
vertices V is some subset of see what
subset will become clear the edges
correspond to all tuples C 1 through C R
plus one which satisfy a non-trivial
linear relation such that summation
lambda i see i equals 0 for some lambda
i's and we might as well restrict
ourselves to minimal sets of points
which satisfy our linear relations okay
so this is some R plus 1 hyper graph on
the vertices here and if a node is not
participating in any relations of in any
edges of this hyper graph I just throw
it out so that is why the vertices are
some subset of this point of the all the
points in the code ok and now I'm going
to use this hyper graph to come up with
this large K minus 1 dimensional sub set
using the obvious greedy algorithm right
so here is an algorithm build up K minus
1 dimensional subset a large K minus 1
dimensional sub set basically we just
greedily keep choosing edges I'm not
sure what's Creedy about it you just
choose edges from this hyper graph every
time you're getting R plus 1 points but
you know that the dimension of your set
is only growing by are the only tricky
part is that you don't want to actually
allow the set to ever reach dimension
key right you want to stop at K minus 1
so we just need one line of code to
account for this kiss right so you start
off from your set s being the empty set
and you keep repeating the following
experiment you pick a point C which is
not in s currently so okay so wide the
dimension of this set s is strictly less
than K minus 1 you take some point which
is linearly independent of the things
which are currently in your set C not in
I should say span of s
okay and which participates and C
participates in some edge which means
that it's a vertex of this hyper graph
so add an edge e containing C now as I
said so what we're doing is the obvious
thing so we have a set s it's dimension
is not full currently okay so one thing
I forgot to mention what does the
property of data locality mean in this
point of view if you had all symbol
locality then every single point would
participate in an edge if you only have
data locality the only thing you can
guarantee is that the set of points
which participate in some edge it is
fully dimensional so as long as s has
not grown to fully dimension you'll be
able to find a point out there which
increases the span of s that you can add
right and an eyes not an edge e
containing C to s now we have to be a
bit careful about you know adding this
edge and actually hitting full dimension
so you'll only do this in the following
so this you actually I guess I just rub
it out and write it again so picky which
is this thing you take an edge e take
edge E containing s containing C so if
adding
if adding this edge to s doesn't make
your dimension full if the dimension of
this union is less than equal to K minus
one addict
else only add a subject
add a subset B prime of e so add a
subset so that the dimension actually
just becomes K minus 1 and you stop
right there
because you don't want the head
dimension key okay so how large a set
did we get by this procedure so
basically what's going on is that for
every increase of our in the rank you're
guaranteed that the cardinality is at
least increasing by R plus 1 right so by
the time the size grows to K minus 1
the sorry by the time the rank grows to
K minus 1 the cardinality has grown to
something which is basically a factor of
R plus 1 over R times K minus 1 and this
is basically what this lower bound tells
you for the lower bound here is saying
that this there is a set of size roughly
k plus K over R which has dimensional
Nikki minus 1 so let me write this down
in some detail the way to actually do
this analysis would be as follows let si
be the number of points added at step I
and let RI be the rank increase so what
we know is that si equals RI plus 1 for
every step except possibly the last
where maybe you hit K so then you just
have to throw in a linearly independent
set of points into your collection now
we know that the final rank sums to K
minus 1 and at each step you know the
rank is only increasing by our at most
so there are K over R steps or rather
you know yeah so here is where you have
to do this case analysis carefully since
I only have five minutes left
I don't think I'm going to be able to do
it but the total rank sums to K minus 1
in L steps and each step the rank can
only increase by R so you know there's
only this two
I did buy there have to be at least this
divided by our steps and at each step
your cardinality is increasing by one
more than this so summation of si is at
least K minus 1 plus ceiling of K minus
1 over other not exactly what I promised
you
but that's where this case analysis
comes in you do it correctly and you'll
get exactly that so ok so how do you
finish the argument we found a set of
cardinality is something like this whose
dimension is only K minus 1 and then we
just appeal to this we say that look the
distance get AK must be n minus the size
of the set because just by deleting
everything outside the set I have shrunk
the dimension so this is exactly what
your bond is see so actually by looking
at this proof carefully you can derive a
lot of information about the structure
of this hyper graph when this bond holds
with equality the situation where the
bound holds with equality is the
following that you go on adding these
edges of size R plus 1 the rank is
increasing by r at every step in the
last step however you hit dimension key
so then you give back a couple of points
you only get to increase cardinality by
r minus 1 and rank also by r minus 1 and
from that you can conclude things like
look this hyper graph looks very simple
it basically consists of a bunch of
disjoint edges of size exactly R plus 1
because if there was a smaller edge
there you would do better in this
algorithm so think of this as a greedy
algorithm which is trying to you know
increase the rank by getting a really
large set small edges are good for you
because instead of pink R plus 1 to
increase the rank by r maybe you know if
I get a smaller edge then I'm doing
better in the analysis of the algorithm
similarly intersecting edges are also
good for you because for the same reason
they allow you to build up the size of
the set even more by
less in the rack I found that we can
conclude that Gold's like this you know
so I again I'm hiding a lot of details
here but in the setting but B is really
small you can conclude that these D
parity-check vertices they just have to
be isolated vertices there's no room for
them to have edges because either those
edges would be too small or they would
overlap with other edges so now in the
five minutes remaining I'd like to show
you at least one construction of a code
which achieves all symbol locality and
meets this bound exactly I'm going to
show you this construction due to
silverstein at all which is based on
capital encodes so this construction
it's going to be yeah so it's based on
linearized polynomials so first some
parameters so if you want a code of
dimension key your message space you
start off with a field F which is 2 to
the N where n well actually let me call
it 2 to the N prime n prime will be
related to the final length n of the
code as n prime is n times some small
constant factor okay I'm going to make
all kinds of divisibility assumptions
here so we have our codes are going to
live in this field F 2 to the N prime
it's a large extension field of F 2 the
polynomials are going to be of the
following shape they're going to be
polynomials of linearized degree k minus
1 which is all things of the form C I
times X to the 2 to the I I going from 0
to K minus 1
and the reason these are called
linearized polynomials is because the
following property which is quite easy
to check which is P alpha 1 plus alpha 2
is P alpha 1 plus P alpha 2 this tells
us that the kernel to 0 SEC okay so this
is you can view this polynomial as a
linear transformation over f2 when you
view f2 to the N as a vector space over
F 2 and the set of zeros it's going to
be a subspace it can have cardinality at
most 2 to the K minus 1 because it is a
polynomial a univariate polynomial of
that degree so the dimension of the 0
set the dimension of X such that px is 0
is less than equal to K minus 1 right so
these are the facts of about linearized
polynomials that we need to know so now
here's their construction it's really
nice and elegant the first thing you do
is to pick a basis for F 2 to the n
prime let's call that alpha 1 through
alpha N Prime and then you just write
down the reed-solomon encoding but only
of linearized polynomials at all these
points so you have P at alpha 1 through
P alpha n Prime now what you do is to
break these into groups of size R each
all these coordinates you break them
into groups of size R there's no
locality at this point and they're going
to create this locality now in addition
to these points I'm going to write down
the evaluation P at the point alpha 1
plus alpha 2 plus alpha R which by
linearity it just happens to be the
parity check of all these entries same
at P alpha 1 plus P alpha 2 plus P alpha
do this for every coordinate do this for
every group brother right so to have a
picture in mind we started off with a
basis for the space okay so what is the
length of the code well for every R I
added one more parity check so the
length is n prime times R plus 1 over R
which is it to have a picture in mind
here is what we are doing we took a
basis alpha 1 to alpha n for the entire
space we group these into things of size
R and for each group we added the
evaluation at one more point in that
group so this is the code now what is
the distance of this code right so
so you know what the so so here we're
just going to use this theorem but just
to say that you know so what is the
largest set of points on which a
polynomial like this could vanish it can
vanish on a K minus 1 dimensional
subspace what is the largest subset of
this set of points which only has
dimension K minus 1 again you do the
obvious thing which is whenever you take
all these points you better take the
point which is linearly dependent on
them and you go on doing that ok
and if you do it this way the distance
that you the number of points at which
you know what is the size of the set
over which it could vanish it will come
out to be something like K minus 1 plus
K over R minus 1 which exactly matches
what it should be there I'm doing this a
bit briskly so it's basically to get a K
minus 1 dimensional subspace you'll do
the obvious greedy thing that you'll
basically be able to choose these many
groups for them you'll get this one
extra point which is linearly dependent
on the others in the last group you will
not have enough dimension to take the
last linearly dependent so let me just
I'm out of time here so let me just wind
up here by pointing out one stronger
property that the school has which I
think is extremely natural in particular
it implies the distance property that we
want which is that finally so we started
off by picking alpha 1 to alpha n prime
as a basis and then we added this alpha
1 through alpha R an additional point
right but really these are plus 1 points
are very symmetric in the sense that any
R of them form a basis right I take our
points the first group are out of our
plus 1 from the second group and so on
and so forth I get a basis for the
entire space so what this tells us is
that if I take this code and puncture
one coordinate per local group the
restriction is an MDS code right because
then you're back to the univariate
polynomial being evaluated at a bunch
of linearly independent work so this is
a stronger property which I'm just
hinting at I leave it as an exercise for
you to check that this actually implies
optimal distance this in some sense is
the strongest property you could hope
for from a code which has this local
structure in it and we'll hear more
about this in tomorrow's talk thank you
you just it's awkward erasers and these
that really all you have to worry about
- yeah because these are disks right so
if a disc is not responding or it yeah
that is a you know so I mean if you're
thinking about internal disk bits
getting corrupted and so on that is a
problem but that's taken care of by the
aeration coding at a disk level here it
seldom happens that I asked this disc
for some data and it gives me absolute
junk he was asking about LDC I guess and
that it really is AirAsia's sorry errors
versus errors
yes yes versus errors it was mainly
about our seals so the condition is that
for my coordinates there would be a
single low weight complaint that
involves the sparrows check this is much
weaker when you have it in LDPC code
right so there you would want to have a
basis of the dual space before when is
over there so I mean this is much bigger
but then he also but I should also
mention that other bus well this is so
low locally the cone pocos so there the
conditions affect much stronger than any
of the DC curves so in ldcs in local
decodable codes you want the whole info
Oh for do constraints then if you take
any coordinate then not only it should
participate with in many many of this we
need to have some nice I can expand them
what that exactly but it's in fact much
more interesting the duals the basis for
the dual space be explained by Sherdog
vectors so LD disease is common in FCS
and Elvis